j'ai voulu piéger les chroniqueurs avec
un sapin de noël
je suis quand même le plus relou du
monde voilà je vous le dis en fait on
leur a fait faire un truc on leur a dit
qu'il fallait dire joyeux noël aux
téléspectateurs et je m'étais caché dans
un faux sapin
regardez bien les réactions sont
diverses avant de voir notre arrivée en
finlande
ces gens viennent chez moi
[Musique]
ok c'est damas après la tuque mais par
la wei ji ici et je vois mal assez en
fait c'est pour la chef du fai salut
c'est benjamin on est en laponie pour
cette fête de noël etc
salut à tous je vous souhaite un très
bon noël un joyeux noël je suis en la
police je suis prêt du père noël pour
tous vos messages étaient pas à me
téléphona qu'on fait peur
[Applaudissements]
les supports n'ont alors pas des trucs
comme ça avec de tous je te promets j'ai
fait la gueule jusqu'à ce qu'un vrai
quoi moi j'aime bien ce qui peut s à
rigoler matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
c'est un pari ce montage un truc que
sans papiers un truc vous connaissez
vous connais je vous connais mais fut
pas du goût des ja oui moi ouais tu sors
ton ami web était parée de l'antenne
alors oui c'est ça j'avais à mes débuts
je pense que vous pouvez faire ce que
vous êtes donc moi je sors mes joies et
les méthodes
voilà merci mon dieu là là là ici un
recul un peu m voilà tu as regardé si tu
regarde ici mais après tu regardes nous
regardons donc pas les intrus qui va du
sort mais c'est lui qui la regarde elle
si forte c'est pas de ma faute
le pauvre tiers ça depuis une heure et
demie les cas battu sa présence
un truc là et noël à tous ça veut dire
quoi repousser 10 à 12 je peux pas
regarder la vie qui se comprend pas
c'est quoi l'histoire
cette annonce était la forme évasée tout
artiste au regard non mais m'en fous je
vous retrouve voile alors non je fais
cela rend chez la limmat un animateur du
leader tnt
voilà les épaules d'ancienne dély
ibrahim ne disait mot lab est bon mais
si valve deux autres il ne faut le faire
bah tu fais un truc rapide alors on le
faire à deux pas du tout là mais je dois
l v6 hockey et dans la zone ouest ce
regard-là foot
allez tu fais un truc escouade en tout
champions trois ans après top web les
mineurs étant allés une heure mesuré que
de plus on peut dire je te mettais des
cinésites hommage change du ville me
l'apport une bonne garde
je sens pas mais tu pas du tout dans la
vaccine top animateurs attention trois
rappels comme les amis
[Musique]
c'est jamais revenir dans ce championnat
[Applaudissements]